[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
this morning we take a look at an
important issue for people with
disabilities
wheelchair safety more than 2.7 million
americans rely on wheelchairs to get
around but every year
more than a hundred thousand are injured
in wheelchair related accidents
omar villafranca shows us one family's
extraordinary push
to make wheelchairs safer
[Music]
as a grammy-nominated songwriter barry
dean is credited with
several top billboard hits but his best
work
may be this you take off and i'll follow
you his daughter's new wheelchair
catherine now 20 was born 16 weeks early
and with cerebral palsy
the diagnosis would change her life and
the lives of her parents
she deserves to be independently mobile
you want that for her but it's
terrifying barry and his wife jennifer
remember
shopping for katherine's first power
wheelchair when she was only
four the speed setting on the chair
hadn't been adjusted
and she tapped the thing and it took off
down the hallway
and the salesperson and i jumped on and
grabbed on it drug us down and ran into
the wall
she was fine you know everything was
fine but it scared us
what kind of protection is available on
just regular wheelchairs nowadays
a seat belt it's really just a seat belt
catherine's back
has screws in it it's the spine is fused
if she flips off of a curb
and all that weight falls on her it
would be catastrophic
[Music]
in some ways wheelchair accidents can be
more dangerous for the rider
than car crashes but while safety
technology like collision avoidance
has made vehicles safer over time barry
learned power wheelchairs
lagged behind and that struck a chord
we couldn't believe that it didn't exist
i'm not willing to spend
10 or 20 years of catherine's life
waiting for someone else to make it a
priority to do the right thing
he sought the help of his brother jared
an engineer
and the siblings went to work to make
catherine's wheelchair
smarter there are problems that are
intellectually
challenging and then there are problems
that you really care about
and this is the first time in my life
that both of those have hit at the same
time
that's a pretty powerful combination
after three years of trial and error
the result is lucy an add-on hardware
and software system for power
wheelchairs
you've got cameras and ultrasonics and
radar millimeter wave radar technology
named after catherine's favorite beatles
song lucy has grown from a family
passion project
into a company it does collision
avoidance so you won't
run into people or things or pets it
does drop
off protection so you won't drive off
curbs or or have those kinds of
catastrophic
problems and then it tip over warning
and alerts time magazine called it one
of 20 20's best inventions
what was it like seeing your daughter in
that chair for the first time
it was just such a relief you know she
loves to be outside she loves to be able
to drive around the neighborhood and to
have just a little bit less stress
in our world was a great thing and for
the accomplished songwriter
it may be his greatest hit doing good
as a dad it's emotional i love you i
mean because you
really want her to feel
free and to be able to do what she wants
are you going fast for cbs this morning
omar villafranca
dallas when they say it's his biggest
hit
that means a lot because he's written he
wrote pontoon and day drinking for a
little big town
yes diamond rings and mold barstools for
tim mcgraw this man is an accomplished
songwriter so that is that's a huge hit
bravo well done and i love that his
brother's an engineer i know that he
said
i like that he said i'm not going to sit
around for 20 years and wait for someone
else to do this
i'm going to do it myself and i love the
name lucy it's so friendly